allez on continue ce Z avec du sport et
un arrêt sur le chantier du moment à 6
mois de l'ouverture du vélodrome de 50
ans en iveline mais oui ça se rapproche
à grand pas Antony reche a fait le point
sur l'évolution du chantier où l'arène
de BMX sort de terre et pour la première
fois nous avons pu pénétrer sur l'aire
centrale de la piste des images signé
hodoine 2 mois après notre dernière
visite au sein du chantier du vélodrome
de saintel nous sommes à nouveau sur le
chantier et juste derrière moi se trouve
l'arène la structure du de la future
arène de BMX et pour relater l'évolution
du chantier évidemment Arnaud sua
monsieur Vélodrome le directeur général
adjoint d'exploitation de vélopolis
bonjour à vous bonjour Anthony je le
disais Arnaud nous sommes venus il y a
de mois et il y a de mois il n'y avait
rien sur cette partie du chantier la
structure est née ça évolue très très
bien malgré les orages et les
intempéries oui oui l'équipe fait un
très beau travail c'est assez complexe
dans les conditions météo qu'on a en ce
moment mais on avance à raison à peu
près une trame par semaine donc ça veut
dire que voyez derrière moi qu' sont en
train d'assembler la dernière trame au
sol et donc d'ici la fin de cette
semaine milieu de semaine prochaine la
dernière trame devrait être posée
assemblée après il restera d'autres
étapes de couverture mais ça avance
plutôt bien cette structure parlons-en
un petit peu c'est c'est du métal c'est
de l'aluminium comment comment ça
s'articule c'est une structure en métal
assez assez dense un peu comme sur la
charpente du Vélodrome donc c'est je
pourrais pas vous donner le tonnage
exact mais c'est une grosse grosse
infrastructure euh c'est une des
premières de ce type en Europe puisqu'il
existe qu'une salle aujourd'hui de BMX
couverte qui se trouve à Manchester donc
qui est même fermée celle-ci sera
couverte et laissera des capacités
d'évolution à l'avenir et elle permettra
à tout à toute l'élite et également au
club et au grand public de s'entraîner
au sec été comme hiver sous nos pieds
donc arrivera la fin de la structure
puisque quelques mètres plus loin
derrière nous se posera le le dernier
mur en fin de compte oui oui alors
sachant que ce sera également ouvert sur
l'espace Vélodrome ce qui créera
vraiment une convivialité entre les
différents espaces de l'ensemble du site
pour que les spectateurs puissent se
balader ou avancer entre le vélorome
l'air multifonctionnel et la plateforme
de BMX assez librement euh oui ça va
arriver vraiment au limite de rampe de
rampe de départ la rampe de 8 m et la
rampe de 4 M5 pour pour l'accès tout
public nous sommes un peu chanceux
aujourd'hui puisque le soleil est revenu
sur le chantier mais ces dernières
semaines ça a été plutôt compliqué
beaucoup d'orages des violents orages
qui ont frappé les evvelin il y a pas eu
de risque de d'électrocution avec avec
avec cette structure on a été les les
équipes B sont très bien formé à ce
genre de risque mais effectivement on a
eu la foudre qui s'est abattu sur la
structure sans causer de dommage juste
juste avant les équipes s'étaient
arrêtées parce qu'elles sentaient que ça
devenait un petit peu un petit peu
inquiétant et donc voilà tout c'est tout
s'est bien déroulé pas d'incident
beaucoup de professionnalisme à souligné
et dans les condition actuelles c'est
important de le le démontrer parce que
c'est pas c'est pas évident de faire
avancer un chantier à ce rythme là dans
dans les conditions que que l'équipe a
connu concernant la piste en elle-même
quand est-ce qu'on va voir naître un peu
ces boss c'est c'est des des roulement
de terrain alors la piste en elle-même
va commencer à être tracée aux alentours
du mois d'octobre puisque encore pas mal
de travail à faire au niveau des
fondations du balisage de la finition de
la couverture de la charpente donc aux
alentours du mois d'octobre la piste
devrait être dessinée bon une fois que
une fois que les équipes pour dessiner
la la piste sont là ça va assez vite en
15 jours de temps la piste est tracée
cette piste elle sera vous savez à peu
près ses longueurs euh le tracé qui le
fait par exemple cette piste elle aura
une première ligne droite de 80 m de
long il y a eu beaucoup de discussions
entre 80 m 110 m ou plus aujourd'hui les
normes de BMX sont assez floues sur le
sujet euh donc on est parti plutôt sur
une une première piste à 80 m qui permet
de couvrir largement l'ensemble des
besoins et qui risque également d'être
la future norme UCI euh puisque le BMX
reste une discipline outdoor mais qui
peut qui ne peut se pratiquer qu'au sec
donc ça veut dire que potentiellement
les futures homologations pourrai de de
de compétition internationale pourrai se
faire uniquement sur des salles fermées
ou couvertes et donc par définition
rendre des des premières lignes droites
plus contenu que celle qu'on a pu
connaître au dernier j de Londres qui
faisait 125 m par exemple ça veut dire
que peut-être dans l'avenir on pourrait
avoir une compétition internationale qui
se déroulerait ici si le si la piste est
homologuée euh sûrement j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est c'est plus c'est plus
que peut-être euh sur sachant qu'on
s'est également par cette structure
couverte non fermée on s'est laissé la
possibilité si demain il était
nécessaire de de rajouter une tramée
supplémentaire de toiture pour étendre
la piste donc on est sur une piste qui
n'est pas figée qui reste évolutive et
donc on a toutes les cartes en main pour
pouvoir candidater à un championnat du
de France d'Europe voire même un
championnat du monde l'idéal ce serait
d'avoir le championnat du monde juste
avant les j en 2016 pour pour les
épreuves qualificatives pour Rio vous le
disiez tout à l'heure ici il y aura une
liaison vers le vélodrome le vélodrome
est à ma droite droite à votre gauche
l'aspect extérieur le bardage évolue
aussi très vite on voit que c'est
presque terminé la couverture ouou ça ça
avance très très vite je dirais que
c'est c'est peut-être ce qui avance le
moins vite par rapport à l'intérieur
puisqueà l'intérieur on est vraiment en
phase de finition le l'ensemble du
chantier on va dire dans les dans le
gros œuvre devrait être terminé d'ici la
fin du mois de juillet donc d'ici un
mois un gros
mois pour après voir la pose de la piste
à partir du mois d'août très bien bah je
vous propose d'aller à l'intérieur de
voir les les dernières évolutions ces
dernièr semain très bien
allons-y
Arnaud nous voici désormais à
l'intérieur du Vélodrome on est juste
au-dessus du deuxè étage où serons
peut-être bientôt poser les les futurs
sièges des tribunes qu'est-ce qui a
évolué ces deux derniers mois al depuis
votre venue on a donc fini de couler
l'ensemble de l'air centrale en béton là
où se déroulera la majorité des
activités annexes autrre que le cyclisme
l'ensemble des rambardes du niveau
supérieur ont été positionné également
de façon à ce que d'ici au 20 juillet on
puisse débuter la pose des sièges de
gradin pour que au 12 août
l'architecte qui vient poser l'ensemble
de la piste puisse être complètement
autonome dans un Vélodrome finalisé hors
poussière on va dire et puis ensuite
avoir les les autres échéances d'ici
d'ici au 13 décembre la date de
livraison du Vélodrome je vois aussi que
certaines bouches d'aération ont
commencé à être à être comblé là-bas du
côté du salon olympique les vitres ont
été posées oui al on est en train de
rendre le vélodrome hors d'air et hors
d'au bon il il était déjà hors d's si ce
n'est par certaines bouches d'aération
où la pluie battante p pouvez encore
pénétrer à l'intérieur du Vélodrome donc
d'ici la fin de semaine prochaine le
vélodrome devrait être complètement clos
manquera plus que les portes vitré du
parvi mais on sera totalement hermétique
dans dans très peu de temps les
prochaines étapes vous le disiez c'est
la pose des des fauteuils très bientôt
c'est c'est une étape déjà importante on
va commencer à imaginer un petit peu
plus l'intérieur du Vélodrome on va
commencer à avoir des couleurs à voir un
petit peu les l'ensemble des volumes oui
oui ça va être une étape importante il y
a à peu près 5000 sièges à poser donc le
l'équip encore une fois un peu de un peu
de pain sur la planche au niveau des des
dates principales on en parlait en
préparant l'émission vous me disiez que
le calendrier s'affine de jours en jour
et on voit déjà un peu les prochaines
portes ouvertes les prochaines
manifestations oui alors les dates clés
qu'on peut qu'on peut retenir c'est le
13 décembre donc la livraison du
bâtiment du
Vélodrome tout début tout début janvier
la Fédération prendra possession de ces
quartiers au bâtiment hébergement et
puis pour débuter les entraînements ici
le 30 janvier il y aura jeudi 30 janvier
il y aura une inauguration protocolaire
avec 5000 invités et puis le 1er et 2
février il y aura des journées portes
ouvertes grand public pour que le grand
public puisse venir visiter cette arène
découvrir les activités physiques et
sportives qui seront proposées
ponctuellement ou au quotidien est-ce
que vous commencez déjà à avoir des
contacts avec des clubs des fédérations
autres que la fédération de cyclisme qui
sont intéressé par l'espace qu'il y aura
ici pour des compétitions autres oui le
parc d'arénas Sportiv ou d'enceintes
sportives de la région parisienne et de
France sont globalement assez
vieillissantes donc il est dès qu'un
club accède à un niveau européen sur la
région parisienne que ce soit en bal en
basket en volet les contraintes de salle
et de J spectateurs se font tout de
suite sentir donc on a des contacts des
différentes fédérations des différentes
ligues également et puis de quelques
clubs qui cherchent à pouvoir optimiser
leur volume leur volume de billetterie
et puis offrir un show toujours à
proximité de la région parisienne enfin
à proximité de Paris en région
parisienne pour pouvoir préserver euh
leur potentiel supporters et les et les
et les convi au fait qu'ils organisent
Bercy va fermer aux alentours du mois de
février pour à peu près 18 à 24 mois de
travaux et nous nous ouvrirons au mois
de janvier donc on se positionne
aujourd'hui avec une jauge de 6000
spectateurs comme la deuxème arène
derrière Bercy et donc on devrait avoir
de de belles sollicitations sur au moins
toute la durée des travaux de parisby
avant le mois de janvier il y aura
d'autres étapes je vous propose de nous
donner rendez-vous fin juillet pour la
pose des des fauteuils et puis mi-août à
peu près pour la pose de la piste merci
beaucoup de nous d'avoir encore une fois
ouvert les portes du Vélodrome et à très
bientôt merci à bientôt voilà et on
suivra régulièrement lesavancé du
chantier dont l'ouverture enfin en tout
cas la livraison est prévue au 13
décembre on l'a entendu